after a rocky few weeks battling the
deep state Trump finally has a
legislative win with the backing of
President Trump the House approved a ban
on abortions after 20 weeks of pregnancy
my favorite kind of ban right after
travel and Ray the point is we finally
have some good old-fashioned
conservative legislation moving through
Congress America is back on track and I
couldn't be more thrilled but some
people are having a hard time
celebrating including one of the bills
co-sponsors congressman Tim Murphy this
story is too much with congressman Tim
Murphy who is under fire this morning
after a Pittsburgh post-gazette story
claims the pro-life congressman urged a
woman he was having an affair with to
get an abortion Murphy's office declined
to comment or respond to the story
classy guy classy indeed but I meant it
sarcastically
this is just another example of a
conservative in the streets and a
liberal in the sheets he's pretending
pretending to be anti-abortion just to
get that sweet pro-life super PAC money
it's a lot of money I should know I'm
pro-life myself now as you may know I'm
a man and as a man I enjoy splaining the
finer points of women's issues but I
don't have time to deal with this
fallout on feminist twitter so I've
invited citizen journalist Laura gray a
woman to help me sort through this Laura
gray everyone the mainstream media is
really going after this guy do you think
he deserves it
well as you know Jordan I got my start
as a conservative mommy blogger I
believe in strong family values
traditional gender roles and that
jeggings are the devil's pants so when
it comes to congressman Tim Murphy
I am vehemently pro-choice oh really
you're you're pro-choice oh yes I
support a man's right to choose to be a
hypocrite now Tim Murphy is exercising
his right to have complete autonomy over
his ability to say one thing and do
another his mouth his words his choice
hey media keep your hands off his body
I mean he did go against his principles
can we not hold him to that Tim Murphy
his first plan was to oppose abortion
and then his mistress had a pregnancy
scare so we moved on to plan B it's
totally legal
Plan B is very effective and should be
accessible to everyone you know it's too
easy to pass judgment from the outside
we live in a culture where being a
hypocrite is unfairly stigmatized now
did you know that one in three men will
be hypocrites by the time they're 45
really well none of my friends are
hypocrites okay that's what you think
Jordan maybe they just don't want to
talk about it because of the liberal
shame machine yeah well maybe they
should have been more caring
it is 2017 I can't believe we're still
having this conversation look in this
last election our country voted to put a
hypocrite in the White House which means
men don't have to hide anymore they can
demand to see a birth certificate but
refuse to release their taxes they can
promise to drain the swamp but hire half
of goldman sachs the days of back-alley
hypocrisy are over
all right you're right I'm I'm only
adding to the stigma that society puts
on men who say one thing and do another
which is crazy because I've been a
hypocrite like what I said there were no
pets allowed in the office but then you
showed up with that owl you found yes I
mean an owl is a hunting tool and I'm
doing it again no judgment Jordan you
know I completely support you now let's
go protest a Planned Parenthood sounds
great Laurie gray everybody